Here's the state transition diagram for
a simple non-deterministic
Turing machine.
The machine starts out in Q zero,
and then it can move the head to
the right upon reading a zero or a one.
Or, upon reading a one,
it can transition to state Q one,
again moving the head to the right.
This is the non-deterministic part.
For a given state and
symbol red, there's more than one
possible transition to follow.
In branches where this transition
is followed, the machine
reads one more zero one and then
expects to hit the end of the input.
Remember that by convention if there's
not transition specified in one of these
state diagrams, then the machine simply
moves to the reject state and halts.
That keeps the diagrams
from getting cluttered.
My question to you, then, is what
language does this machine recognize?
Check the appropriate answer.